اهلا ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في حلقه
جديده من المقابله استضيف فيها المثقف
والاكاديميه الفرنسيه
الباحث الذي قضى جانبا طويلا من حياته في
العالم العربي كيف ترى اوروبا واقع
الاسلام والمسلم
ما هي طبيعه هذه الازمه في العلاقه في
برايك عنصريه ضد المسلمين ليست قد يا
اوروبيه فقط اذا ننظر الى السين مثلا الى
منظور الى الهند حاليا ولكن فيما يخص
اوروبا اسمحوا لي ربما ان اركز على
النموذج الفرنسي لماذا لان كلنا موافقين
ان الوضع الفرنسي حاليا اسوا من اي بلد في
اوروبا ينقسم التحليل اعتقد الى جانبين
جانب تاريخي لماذا انتقلت المجتمعات
الاوروبيه الى هذا النوع من التوتر مع
المسلمين وجانب حالي تنافس بين القوى
السياسيه في موضوع وحيد وهو التعامل مع
المسلمين في الماضي الخطاب الاسلاموفوبي
كان محدود الى فئات معينه من المجتمع
الفرنسي اليمين المتشدد المتطرف اليمين ثم
انتقل الى اجزاء من اليسار غيرنا ابتداء
من سنه 2019 هذا الخطاب العنصري اصبح ختاد
الدوله
نجرب فلانه شيء فشيء بدات نقول نجرب فلان
وجيرانهم اقريبهم اخيهم لماذا لانهم تنتمي
الى بيئه فلان
الخلفيه التاريخيه لصعوبات العلاقات بين
المسلمين وفرنسا تنقسم الى ثلاث ابعاد اول
تنافس بين الاديان
فرنسا تنظر اليه كانه مجتمع مسيحي والتنظر
الى الاسلام دين اجنبي اللايكيه الفرنسيه
العلمانيه المتجدده الفرنسيه التي جاءت من
ظروف الثوره الفرنسيه احفظ
المستعمرين يرفضون وجود احفاد المستعمرين
يرفضون الناس احفاد المستعمرين يرفعون
صوتهم في في المجتمع الفرنسي ماذا يريد
احفاد المستعمرين الفرنسيون المسلم الان
اعتراف
بحقوقهم
تعرف ان اذا اسمك محمد تبحث العمل في
فرنسا تذيع خمسه او سته مرات
الوقت الذي يحتاج خصوه او بخناق لايجاد
عمل مطالبه قد تكون دينيه ما طبيعه العمل
المنظم والموجه لحركات الاسلام السياسي في
فرنسا
الجماعيه كل مؤسسات المسلمين الناشئين حتى
ولو في الدفاع
حقوق
المواطنين المسلمين الدوله الفرنسيه
غادرت فتره دوله القانون لما قام بالغاء
بحل جمعيات التحالف ضد اللسان في فرنسا
والناس ما كانوا تنتمي الى اي تيار سياسي
كانوا مواطنين مسلمين نايشيتين لمعالجه
التوتر بين الحكومه والمسلمين الخطاب
الاسلام الاسلامي لقوا حلفاء خارج فرنسا
اولا تتذكر ربما
شارون في الفائده
واثنين واحد بقى شارون عندكم بن لادن
عندنا ليس حماس ليس حركه المقومون
الاسلاميه عندنا ياسر عرفات فما هو خلفيه
مثل هذا الختار نركز على الانتماء او
الديني من المنافس او من المعارض كيف تعرف
الدوله الفرنسيه الاسلام السياسي فيمنعونك
المشاركه في النقاش بالزرع ان انت تغذي
التشدد الاسلامي وانت شريك من سوف
يقتلهم انا اعتقد ان مشكل فرنسا في ما يخص
علاقاتها مع الجيران
والاغلبيه تخاف من الاغلبيه لما تصل الى
سوريا تركز على الاقل المسيحيه لما تصل
الى بلد عربي تركز على البربر لما امام
جمهور من الذكور تركز كيف يؤثر الخارج على
مجريات داخل الفرنسي في العلاقه ما بين
الدوله والمسلمين اذا ذكرت جانب من هذا
التعاون
الاقليمي هذا التنسيق خطير جدا تنسيق بين
بعض الانظمه
والحكام الاوروبيين ودوله اسرائيل وتعرف
ان الاتفاقات الاخيره جعلت هذه الظاهره
اوداح بكثير
[موسيقى]